first up he is the US representative for
California's 28th congressional district
and chairman of the House Intelligence
Committee we're hoping he will save us
all Adam Schiff ladies
and I might know why you like to do our
show you get to sleep in your own bed
that is true okay that's true so you put
out an open letter today I read it
interesting stuff and it's funny cuz I
was gonna ask you about this because I
assume you do talk to Republicans after
hours now I know when Obama was
president they complained he didn't
socialize enough with them do you
socialize with them do you talk over
drinks privately we do socialize and and
certainly there are a lot of private
conversations where they will express
their fears misgivings about this
president about his lack of ethics about
his base ok good decent oh you you're
saying in this letter you want them now
to do that publicly what you're saying
over martinis you want to hear publicly
you know people will stop me in the
corridor Republicans and say keep doing
what you're doing really you know even
senior Republicans which of course would
be heresy for them to say publicly I
don't need private confidences
misgivings anymore we need public
statements we need people to take a
stand you need people you need people to
vote their conscience you know that the
president now you know has to declare
this unconstitutional emergency and it's
hard to make a weaker case for an
emergency than the one he's made where
Congress has deliberated for months
about this Congress has rejected his
proposal Congress has come up with a
bipartisan consensus instead on
something else and this for him is an
emergency well it's it's a complete and
run it's an attack on the principle
power of the Congress the power of the
purse right if Republican members who
won't defend their own institution what
hope is there that they'll defend the
judiciary or any anything else in our
system so what makes them fold because I
see them all the time looking like
they're gonna be something that guy
Kennedy from Louisiana John Kennedy was
good for a while
Lindsey Graham was good for a while Mitt
Romney Richard Burr who is the
counterpart right on the Senate
committee yes he seemed like a normal
guy for a while this week he said you
know we've looked at the evidence we
don't see anything that would
make us think the president was involved
in collusion I think Trump is a
blackmailer
what what what what does did they have
pictures of these guys with a duck or
something what what makes these guys
will like that you know he's still
popular in their base and they're
terrified of having a trumpet primary
challenge and that I think cows them
into silence but but you're right it's
it's inexplicable why be there what's
the point of being there why do you
aspire to be a member of Congress if
when the country really needs you you're
missing in action you know the statement
that some of my colleagues have made
there's no evidence of collusion for
example you might as well say there's no
evidence that the president is dishonest
hello if you do you hear the words
coming out of his mouth I mean is all -
all too plain
you know the everybody's waiting on pins
and needles tonight because there may be
a document dropping in the mana Ford
case well if you look at just the mana
Ford case here's the campaign chairman
meeting with someone believed to be
associated with Russian intelligence
offering polling data and apparently not
a top line here's why we think Donald
Trump is going to win but raw data why
is that being provided to the Russians
and why are they lying about it and why
is Roger stone lying about his contacts
with the publishing arms of the Russians
or gusoff or - which is directly of the
GRU why is that Flynn lying about his
contacts you know these and hundred
other communications why all the lies
why all the obstruction why are the
Russians why is every day I hear Kalume
Nick and display via a Nutella cupcake
fisca
I never heard these kind of names before
and when you when you talk about the
corruption that every thing that the
Trump name is associated with is being
investigated the Trump Organization
right the Trump charity was the Trump
University the campaign the inaugural I
mean I read today in the New York Times
the
or I guess it was yesterday that he went
to the he asked Whittaker who was the
temp attorney general for a few months
asked him to put of somebody who knew
was a supporter in charge of the of the
cohan investigation in New York in the
Southern District
now isn't that itself obstruction of
justice well it certainly looks like
obstruction to me I mean he's trying to
handpick someone to put their hand on
the scale or protect him is you know he
wants a roy cohn in the Southern
District of New York but but you know
here's another thing that just to me is
so telling about how this president has
dumbed down our moral standards you have
two Attorney General's the last two
Attorney General's Matt Whittaker who
auditioned for the part by going on
cable news and saying this is how I
could privately [ __ ] the mo
investigation and then Bill Barr who
basically auditioned the same way both
of them refused to commit to following
the advice of Ethics lawyers is it so
much to ask that the top law enforcement
officer of the country would commit to
following the advice of Ethics lawyers
but apparently that's no longer part of
the job requirement and that is a sad
day in America but it's also part of why
they were chosen but part of why they
were chosen if Bill Barr was going to
commit to following the advice of ethics
lawyers he would have never been
appointed and this is where we are and
and this bill is why I wrote this letter
to my Republican colleagues you know
every day bit by bit
drop by drop we see our democracy
evaporating and you need to look at the
cumulative total of all this and how
much damage is being done and I think my
colleagues have to ask themselves why am
I here if not to defend this beautiful
system we have and speak out and act out
and act my conscience and and whatever
my voters do you know I always tell my
constituents the job of a member of
Congress is not to get reelected it's to
do the right thing and still find a way
to get reelected
the problem is no one who needs to hear
this is hearing it that's the problem do
you get invited on Fox News yes I do I
do and I go on Fox from till you go Sean
how did he invite you on oh he invites
me a lot you don't know I you know I
used to go you shouldn't go go
that's who needs to hear your message
you know I thought you weren't invited
no I am invited I am invited please go
who likes me I do but but I like America
too
you got to get in the bubble Man well
this bubbles this already sewn up we got
these but here's the thing here's the
thing about Fox News and there are
credible journalists some on Fox News
but but just trying to think of
something it's about the audience that's
listening to it no I at least they would
hear the argument the the challenge that
we face and I think this is the
cross-cutting challenge of all and it's
demonstrated by Fox News is we now get
our information from such different
places right and and people live in
their information world my point if
there had been a Fox News when Richard
Nixon was president there would have
been no preemie right and of his
administration you know my favorite
anecdotes like favorite anecdote of
Watergate is because this is so trumpian
you could imagine Trump doing exactly
the same thing when the tapes were
revealed and the White House didn't want
to give out the tapes and didn't want to
make the public didn't wanna give them
to Congress they came up with a solution
we'll give them to James O Eastland
right this old Democratic senator right
we'll let him tell the public what's on
them well he was notoriously deaf right
and you could see Donald Trump saying
this but the difference between then and
now is if Donald Trump proposed that
today mm-hmm
Fox News would say that's a brilliant
idea that's a brilliant idea and and
people who want to go there man all
right you I will go great
I appeal my last question you know I
always ask myself how the Republicans
can abide by the fact that this
president
okay attacking the Democrats we get that
but he attacks the institutions of
government he attacks the FBI the CIA
the Justice Department this is
unbelievable to me and I was trying to
think how could he get away why do they
put up with this but then I thought you
know when a Republican attacks
government that goes back to Reagan
Reagan famously said something like the
scariest nine words in the English
language or I'm from the government and
I'm here to help
hahaha when you lay that groundwork that
the government is evil to begin with
that they can do no right yeah
forty years later Trump comes along and
he says the FBI is crooked people buy it
you think that's what it is you know I
think that what Republicans admired
about Reagan was not just his ideology
which was very clear but the fact that
he projected a sense of decency and a
sense of optimism
I remember feeling as I watched our
president in Helsinki say I believe this
guy Vladimir's PTIN over my own
intelligence agencies I thought to
myself model Reagan once said I didn't
leave the Democratic Party the
Democratic Party left me well the
Republican Party has left Ronald Reagan
okay there's nothing laughs yeah about
him in that party there's no decency in
the leader of their party right there's
no integrity there's no optimism and
Donald Trump's Republican Party America
is a victim I just came from Munich
where we had this security conference
and where the speaker led a delegation
to do our part as article one to
convince our allies that that we value
NATO that we value the European Union
the transatlantic alliance and you know
our allies have profound questions about
whether they can count on America
anymore that's the legacy of this
president that was not Ronald Reagan's
legacy all right congressman Adam Schiff
look for him on Fox News everyone
[Applause]
you